i think the key here is that when one
starts to understand like gosh i'm
really drawn to this thing
that when you understand that one can
start making
taking steps to to move away from it now
the problem with this all dopamine thing
in the context of relationship is that
early on it's incredibly intoxicating to
the point where oftentimes people don't
realize that they're veering
so hard right that that you know and and
this is where the power of friends um
comes in very handy this is also where
we can honestly say that the power of
complete and total disclosure about
relationship to friend or therapist is
really healthy if you're saying like you
know i've seen this with some of my male
friends
i have female friends too but most of my
friends just happen to email at this
stage of life that's just kind of my
surroundings and i get the friend that's
super excited about somebody and they'll
tell you this story about this say oh
you know and there was this crazy thing
she did this crazy thing and they get
kind of wide-eyed and like that doesn't
sound good he's like excited about it
like okay this is this is your this is
his drug right it's uncertainty it's
excitement and i and it follows a very
predictable pattern we're in three to
six months it's
him complaining that she's crazy or that
the relationship is a mess or that the
original thing you love now you hate
exactly there's chaos so i think that
here's the i think the takeaway for
relationships not just at the beginning
not just in the middle um we can talk
about the end in a minute if there is
one but
to have an awareness where if you sense
too much excitement in yourself
or too much anticipation of how great
someone is i'm not saying don't fall in
love but be very cautious about the
extremes of dopamine be very wary about
the thing that makes you feel incredible
and i i say this with some trepidation
because i myself you know love love
right i love love i love love oh but
love falling
best love falling in love love being in
love i mean that's true in romantic
relationships and i also you know i i
love having a bulldog like i loved him
love love love
you know i have so many loves in life
and relationships
are always the best of it right but
there is this element where
it is a bit of a
drug right it's this thing because it's
always about more and if you really want
the relationship if you want good
clarity on the relationship and you want
it to last
there has to be a tempering of that and
i don't mean
playing aloof i don't mean canceling
things last minute i don't mean playing
any kind of games with the dopamine
reward prediction error thing what i
mean is just being aware that
that chemical state
it it really is a what comes up comes
goes down and it also puts tremendous
demand on the other person
right
that i think the key of any good
relationship is to be able to toggle
back and forth ideally in para like
together through these more dopaminergic
like novelty excitement
and then the more like really getting
joy out of just being together the more
serotonergic stuff like that just like
wow the sweetness the the incredible
like the cocoon
um
and missing one another is super healthy
also remember
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring us pleasure making
sure that we continue to derive
excitement from other things in life
even when we're falling in love you know
the concept of the muse and the concept
of
in a new relationship there's we feel
kind of indestructible we can do
anything in life and feeling so inspired
you know you see this people you joyful
excited oh i've seen this in family
members also like working out again and
you're like wow they use it but the
problem is it's all anchored it's all
tethered to this relationship and the
relationship goes and then the rest of
stuff goes too so again being able to
access these motivational reward systems
in a bunch of contacts so critical and
then of course we see the opposite too i
have a lot of friends who've been
married for a long time and they're like
yeah like we never do anything anymore
they're only in that kind of serotonin
you're going to say we never do it
anymore or yeah
and sex is a huge i mean it's
we know one thing for sure which is that
all of us are here because either in a
dish or in a will eventually in a body
sperm egg and develop that's just the
reality and that whole process that we
call sex sexual reproduction
is strongly anchored to what's called
the autonomic arousal system whereby
there's excitement and then but it can't
be too much excitement it's got to be
calm because if it's too much excitement
it actually inhibits the sexual response
that um believe it or not the orgasm
response in both men and women is driven
by the stress system of the body but it
has this positive valence we say it's a
lot of dopamine and then the why because
then afterwards
whatever that happens to be
there's a
return to below baseline levels of
energy this is we think that the just so
story about this is that it's likely so
that people will exchange
smells to pair bond
right because pair bonding is pretty
vital to human
partnership um and
obviously people can have sex not just
to raise to produce and raise young but
then so the whole like seesawing back
and forth and then it repeats right at
whatever frequency that couple is for
them but that whole process is one in
which dopamine is strongly released in
anticipation and during sex and and then
afterwards it plummets and there's
another molecule called prolactin which
skyrockets
prolactin actually sets the refractory
period
in which at least for males sex can't
happen again
and
what are the other things that induce
prolactin in males and females well
child rearing
la it's linked to the lactation
process oh wow the the the like the the
coziness thing is not dopaminergic it's
prolactin it's it's basically driven by
prolactin oxytocin and serotonin so this
seesawing back and forth is is at the
core of who we are it's at the core of
how we got here all our parents one way
or another went through this process
you know i was trying to think of the
exceptions i'm always teased that i
think of every qualify i suppose in in
vitro fertilization the
mother and the father went through this
process in separate areas of the world
but nonetheless each one went through
the process in more standard natural
reproduction as we call it they
took place presumably in the same
place
so
this is how we got here this is how we
work and i think learning to toggle back
and forth between excitement and
anticipation but never hitting that
absolute extreme excitement is a very
useful thing don't ever hit the ceiling
ever in that way you maintain motivation
you maintain excitement and learn how to
toggle back and forth
so is it possible because i'm just
thinking about myself at times in my
life or somebody out there listening
is it possible to both be so excited and
connected that you feel that huge drive
and push to like mate and be together
and spend time or is that
overly heightened
dopamine or
state
an indication of
an unhealthy
loop or pattern relationship
into people
well i think it can be healthy i mean i
think and also remember dopamine is a
generic molecule so for instance this is
if ever there was a
justification for maintaining a lot of
different interests and things that can
generate dopamine here's one when you're
we talked about before when you're in a
relationship that's really great you
feel more energy to do other things
the substrate by which adrenaline is
created etc
um
well the the opposite is also true you
know you imagine the couple and one is
doing kind of well in life they're
excited about life the other one is not
well the person who's excited about life
is sort of like is in a position to be
more excited about the relationship you
know if you come home from a great day
at work
um or you've got a lot going on you
bring that to the relationship that
dopamine bleeds over it's like because
dopamine is all about possibility it's
like hey let's take a vacation this year
let's or let's take it it could be
simple thing like let's just take a walk
or let's start like going for a swim in
the morning or like it's all about like
let's create newness right so there is a
way in which you could one can leverage
different components of life in order to
be more excited about the relationship
they're in i think that
there's another piece to this which is
you know
which is i think what you're asking
correct me if i'm wrong which is that
you know if it if we're too excited
about the relationship will it
inevitably fail and i think the answer
is no one of the amazing things about
love and relationships is that it's
really about creating a story in one's
mind about the past and what it means
and projecting that story forward and
and that's that's something that is just
incredible right as that's sure mating
isn't sex is involved but it's not just
about that i always joke you know sex is
necessary but not sufficient right you
need the other elements of and and one
of the amazing things about this thing
of love and attachment is that it's not
all just chemicals and neurotransmitters
i don't want to give that impression
it's also about this ability to to write
to mutually write a story
like we met there was this this spark
there was this thing there was this
mutual interest we made it through this
hard thing we you know and the key thing
remember dopamine is about projecting
into the future it is important
to not just have plans but to sort of
take that story and project it into
an infinite number of sequels
not just the one blockbuster picture
that came out and ended and now we're
just going to kind of sit together and
only focus on kids although kids are a
whole other separate beautiful dimension
of this
some people don't want them and
oftentimes people will have them
thinking that it's going to create it's
going to bring novelty to the
relationship i know so many people who
have gotten divorced about seven or
after their kids are about seven to nine
years old i'm like what is going on here
i think that there are a number of
different sort of transitions at that
stage where the kids are no longer
providing a ton of novelty they need
slightly less caretaking although still
substantial amounts of caretaking so i
think that once
one understands how these mechanisms
work you can start to layer them in in
ways that meet people's different life
requirements the other thing is the
breakup part just mentioned this that in
an episode on grieving and breaking of
attachments
the brain has a three-part map of all
attachments whether or not it's to a
person or to an animal romantic or
non-romantic we want to know where they
are in space like literally are they in
paris right now are they here where are
they yeah they are in time like are they
present now when will i see them again
and then there's this attachment map and
those three things are tethered think of
it like a tripod they're tethered when
somebody
when we break up or somebody dies
or if we anticipate that a relationship
is going to end
it the grieving process we know based on
neuroimaging taps into the reward system
and creates a system where we are
anticipating the the reward of love and
attachment and connection but it's never
going to come and that is it it's like
an over activation of
desire desire
when but with the knowledge that there's
nothing right there if someone passes
away we're sometimes familiar with like
turning around expecting to see them the
brain expects to see them because the
brain has seen them every time we've
turned around
you know waking up with the bed empty
next to us is incredibly like it's i
mean we hopefully people experience at
least one breakup in their life i think
it's actually a healthy thing to
experience that maybe get back together
don't do it don't break up just to do
this folks but um but that feeling of
like god like it's like this yearning
well that's the
hungry
animal or human who's the food is just
out of reach
and the grieving process is one of
reordering that map to understand okay
maybe this person is not in their
current physical form they're die
they've died maybe that person isn't
available to us because
there's a breakup yeah understand that
the craving is setting up literally a
pain in the body remember pain and
pleasure are toggling also it's
physical and mental anguish
because
it's right outside our reach and even
though we cognitively understand
that
it's not available to us the body still
wants it and so it takes you know i
think the current estimates based on
imaging and other studies are it's about
60 days of no contact that means no text
no scrolling and seeing their social
media no looking at pictures of them no
listing your favorite songs no selling
their shirts or other things
60 days or so to reset those mechanisms
just to get back to kind of neutral
unless it was a terrible relationship in
which case people are celebrating
what makes someone
have a more emotional breakup than
another
oh that's a great question there's a
phenomenon called um and this is
beautiful work done by mary frances
o'connor at the university of arizona um
she's written a wonderful book about
this there's something called the
complex or complicated grief
complex complicated grief is grief that
goes on much longer and it has a kind of
more of a depressive like state to it
it's the person who's still talking
about the person that they
broke up with or that broke up with them
two years later oh my goodness it's so
annoying to friends and family and yet
that person is really in a in a place of
intense
complicated grief sorry to acknowledge
that and oftentimes if someone died then
that complicated grief can extend even
longer complicated grief is um tends to
happen more in people that have poor
anxiety and stress coping mechanisms
going into the relationship
so like the anxious attachment or avoid
an attachment or something or more of an
anxious attachment could be it could
also be that the person just naturally
um their uh sort of like idling rpm is
higher
we all have this like so for instance
some people move around a lot more just
standing around um some people are just
you know calmer
i always like to compare people to
animals and
bulldog
bulldogs and bulldog breeds for instance
are incredibly like
most of the time unless there's
something to be excited about if you
look at a pit bull type breed or a
terrier they kind of have a lot of
belgian malinois yeah you have a
malinois amazing
[Music]